Hey guys welcome back I'm Nate
thank you for joining me today on the king of random a
Sling is a tool that is thousands of years old used to hurl projectiles at high speeds over long distances
It's been used as a hunting tool and a weapon of war it's light weight has incredible range and best of all for us
it's very easy to make so the purpose of today's video is to show you how to make your own sling at home in just
A few minutes using some low cost materials here are all the supplies
We'll need for this build yarn from any craft or fabric store some drinking straws
I prefer the thicker ones you can often find at fast food restaurants and some twine
This is jute cord also available at most craft and fabric stores, and that's all the supplies You'll need to start
Let's grab one of our straws and our yarn the first step is to tie a simple overhand knot
With your yarn around one of the straws
You'll want to be sure that you leave six to eight inches of extra yarn after your knot
Gather all six straws and hold them in your hand with the yarn attached to the far right straw to begin simply weave the yarn
through the straws
With each straw you need to alternate if the yarn goes in front or behind the straw
When we get to the last straw wrap it around and weave back
Keep weaving the yarn up the straw being sure to pull it tight and slide it all the way down every couple of passes at
First it might be a little hard to hold on to the straws as you weave but it will get easier as the straws get
Wrapped up and held in place by the yarn
There shouldn't be any gaps in your yarn always press it down so that the different layers are touching each other
We've now woven our yarn nice and tightly together about six inches wide
So it's cut off our excess yarn and set this aside for a moment and prepare our twine
Let's measure out six pieces of twine each piece should be ten feet long
With our lengths of twine cut let's feed one through each of the six straws
Before we remove the straws we want to be sure that the yarn pocket is in the center of the lengths of twine
gather together all six ends of the twine on both sides
Being careful to keep the two sides separate from each other hold them in one hand and stretch the pocket and straws
Away from them if the straws aren't centered on the twine pull on the short side until the straws are right in the middle
With the straws and yarn centered on the twine it's time to carefully remove the straws holding the yarn so that the weave doesn't unravel
Gently pull the straws in one uniform direction
You may find that the center straws slide out more easily than the two straws on the edges to
Be sure you didn't accidentally pull any of the twine while you are removing the straws
It's best to line up the edges and make sure the pocket is centered again
If the yarn pocket is too far to one side carefully slide it along the twine to Center it again
Now with our pocket centered we want to tighten it up and cinch it off
Secure all six strands on one side of the twine and begin pushing the yarn down into the middle
Once that side seems fully compacted switch to the other side and do the same thing
The yarn pocket should end up about half as long as it was
once the yarn is compacted into the center you want to grab the extra piece that you left and gently pull it to cinch the
edges
before tightening the side where the weave began be sure to undo the overhand knot you made around the straw the
Pocket is formed so now let's make the cords divide the twine into three sets of two strands
To make the braiding process easier we'll secure the side we're not working on to the table with tape
Now we're ready to begin braiding to make a braid take one of the outside lengths of cords and place it in the middle of
The other to take the cord from the other side and now move it into the middle
Repeat this process over and over and the braid forms
Every so often you'll need to make sure that the back of your twine is not getting tangled be sure to keep the braid nice
And tight by pulling on it there shouldn't be any gaps or holes in the braid
You can choose how long to make your cords, I prefer a length of just over two feet once
You've reached the length that you want simply tie an overhand knot to end the braid
remove any excess twine
With one side complete we want to repeat the process on the other side
When our second braid is about three inches from the length of our first
We're going to add an addition that makes it easier to use
We're going to make two smaller braids select one strand from each of the three bundles
We want to braid each of these three strands together
Keep going until your small braid is approximately 2 inches long then make a second identical braid with the other 3 strands
With the two smaller braids completed. Let's form our double strands again and return to the larger size braid
We only need about half an inch of our larger braid before we tie this off and this side of the cord will be complete
This braided loop gives us something that we can easily hold on to and let go of to facilitate the use of our sling
Your sling is now complete
There are a lot of things that can be used for a mo most traditionally small smooth rocks however
We don't want to be doing any damage with these so what we're going to use is small crumpled-up balls of foil
This is a good size to fit in our sling is lightweight enough that it won't damage anything
But it's heavy enough that it should fly through the air fairly
Well to use our sling take your ammo put it in the pocket of the slingshot and fold it in
You'll then twirl the sling around your head and release from the loop that we made with the small braids
Let's take this outside and try it out
I'll spin this above my head and let go of the side that I'm holding in the loop
My aim is terrible. I'm learning
Well that launched pretty well into the neighbor's yard
So hopefully they won't mind a small piece of foil on their grass a little bit of wind this time
We'll see if that affects anything
That's pretty good had some good zing to it flew kind of straight did not go over the wall just backed into the brick
Let's go see what happened mostly. I'm just curious if it flattened part of the foil I
Think it did it's not very obvious
But I'm pretty sure this is where I hit the wall our whole shot is now a little bit narrower from the impact
Let's try a few more times
That went into the neighbor's yard again, I need to find a better target, so instead. I'm just going to throw it down the street
There's really nothing that can be broken and these little balls of foil probably couldn't break anything anyway
And now I'll be able to go get it. It's not going to go over a fence into someone's yard
Unless I'm a very bad shot in which case
It will we'll see Oh
In someone's yard, but not over a fence. I'm gonna try spinning it in a different direction so it's more
down the street and less in circles above my head oh
There we go that was straight right down the middle of the road if I were David fighting Goliath
I'm pretty sure I'd lose he had a lot more practice than me
Grounder
For me the helicopter and releasing sideways. I keep launching it off to left or right
What's working better for me?
and you should practice this on your own I
Go around and then I come down and up and that's really getting a lot straighter of a shot for me
Let's try things out with the projectile that won't damage anything figure out. What works best for you
I'm gonna try using marshmallows because they're fun
Both taste like really good projectiles and this will work
Still one sideways
And that marshmallow didn't come down it lives in a tree now some squirrel is gonna be so happy now
I'm gonna try and throw marshmallow into the air while grant tries to catch it in his mouth for science. Oh
Oh
In and out in and out
Yeah
New chubby bunny challenge chubby bunnies from a distance long distance chubby bunny long distance show many buddies
I could see this becoming a little sport
perfect alright
Yeah
That was sweet, it was like a wiffle ball. Just move curve ball marshmallow
There you have it how to make your own David and Goliath style sling using just yarn twine and some straws
Like I said all sorts of things can be used as ammo when these were used as weapons of war
They would often use cast pieces of lead and in fact some ancient Greek pieces have been found with inscriptions on them that say things
Like catch or take that now reminder that if you're using any sort of metal or rocks these things can be extremely dangerous
So be sure you're nowhere near any people or fragile objects. I hope you've enjoyed this project
Thank you so much for joining us and we look forward to the next one. Talk to you then and
Then I just that when I just let go early flew off backward random happens
They both go that way
Hey guys, I hope you're feeling happy today
I know I am because you're keeping this channel alive and well we really appreciate your support because we could not be doing this without
You that's why you're the best